hey it's Kennedy for reason TV with
reason magazine editor-in-chief Matt
Welch give us a preview of the october
issue that's on stands now yes so on the
cover we have a piece about the recovery
that wasn't it's actually sort of an
illustrated shark in some way where we
take quotes from every month of the
Obama presidency starting basically with
Ben Bernanke's oh there's green shoots
are starting to appear in the economy
and we put these red blossoms well the
administration if you listen to them
they have I mean every single month some
member of the administration has gone
out in public and said in the words of
Timothy Geithner in an op ad for the new
york times two summers ago welcome to
the recovery they've been saying
consistently that their economic
policies have led to this wonderful
recovery that we've all had and so what
we did is we juxtapose those quotes next
to what the actual unemployment figures
were like during the month at the quote
was uttered just as a kind of comical
although very sad look at how
disappointing the economic performance
of this administration has been despite
the way that it portrays its own
performance and what will be a bigger
help to Mitt Romney the economy in a
shambles the economy the way it is right
now or Paul Ryan's abs and dreamy blue
eyes well Obama says we put the start of
the piece two weeks after he was elected
he gave an interview with CNN and he
said basically four years from now I
will be hired or fired based on did I
get this economy turned around so based
on his own pronouncements he should be
fired just because of that they said if
you pass the stimulus the worst that
unemployment would be is eight percent
and we haven't had it below eight
percent since that time so ultimately I
think yes the economy is going to matter
more even than Paul Ryan I think Paul
Ryan's very interesting character he's a
sign that a bit Romney after running
kind of to the economic left of the
field in the Republican Party was
talking about protecting Social Security
and restoring cuts to Medicare and all
this kind of bad stuff from the
perspective of limited government
enthusiasts he felt the need to pay a
stop to the the strong ground swell on
the kind of grassroots right that you
need an economic and fiscal conservative
there on the ticket well you need a
fiscal conservative which means you
also have to cut defense spending if
you're truly fiscally conservative where
do Romney and Ryan stand on that and
what does that have to do with the
october issue of reason we have a great
piece in the october issue by scott
rasmussen the pollster where he talks
about how you can use polling data to
figure out how to finally cut government
he points out the republicans who claim
to be for cutting government yet don't
want to touch defense by which it means
Mitt Romney and Paul Ryan they actually
hurt the son of the cause of cutting
government because that just means
nothing's ever going to get cut but if
you listen to what Americans want to do
which is be much less entangled in the
world be much less likely to be the
policeman of the world then you can find
a framework for actually cutting defense
spending which absolutely has to happen
or else there's no way you can cut
government and you can't claim to be a
fiscal conservative if you're not
cutting across the board exactly Rand
Paul when he came to the Senate in 2011
basically said if you're serious about
cutting government Democrats have to cut
entitlements Republicans have to cut
defense and you're only gonna read that
reason it's on newsstands now Matt thank
you very much thank you I'm Kennedy for
a reason to be what you think about that